So, we're beginning in September 21, 1913, and this is volume 11. The heading says, "All
the things that the soul does in the divine will, and together with Jesus, acquire his
qualities, his life, and his value." That's an incredible statement, okay? So, I have
a VIP on this one. Louisa says, "This morning my beloved Jesus made himself seen with indescribable
sweetness and affability, as if he wanted to tell me something very dear to him and of
great surprise for me." So, embracing me completely and pressing me to his heart, he
told me, "My beloved daughter, notice pressing me to his heart the same as John at the last
supper." Do you remember that? That's John 13. I haven't got the verse. "My beloved daughter,
all the things that the soul does in my will, and together with me, that means all the prayers,
all the actions, all the steps, etc. They acquire my own qualities, my own life and my
own value." My book says, "My same," which it's not English. See, all the things I did
upon the earth, the prayers, the sufferings, the works, they're all in act. That means
available present now. They're all eternal and therefore present, and will remain in eternity
for the good of whoever wants them. My working differs from the way creatures operate. Now,
for that I want to give you Isaiah 55 verses 8 to 10. My ways are not your ways. My thoughts
are different from yours. Isaiah 55 verses 8 to 10. "Containing the creative power within
myself, I speak and I create." That's terribly important. You have Genesis 1, 3. "God said,
there be light, and there was light." Now, I could give you numerous things from the gospel
where Jesus said, "Get up and walk," and the person was able to get up and walk, because
God's Word is creative. Jesus said, "This is my body, and this is my blood." Okay, and
it happened. So, "I speak and I create." Now, before I move on, I just want to illustrate
that another little bit. If the Lord speaks in your heart, forgive in a particular situation,
he automatically gives you the grace to do it. Forgive is not an order without the wonder
of grace to enable you to do it. He actually helps you to actually put it into practice.
So I speak and I create. Just as one day I spoke and I created the sun as that let there
be light, Genesis 1, 3, and this sun is always full of light and heat, and it always gives
light and heat as if it were in the act of receiving continuous creation from me. Now,
the image that's given to you there is that the creation of the sun is happening instantaneously
all the time. In other words, the divine will is actually keeping it in existence, just
as the divine will is keeping us in existence and keeping everything in existence. So creation
is continuous. So, it is as if it were receiving continuous creation from me without ever decreasing.
What was my operating upon the earth? Since I contain the creative power within myself,
the prayers, the steps, the works that I did and the blood that I shed are in continuous
act of praying, operating, walking, etc. In other words, everything is totally available
to us. When we enter into the divine will, we can enter in and take anything that is
in Jesus and make it our own and use it for the good of souls. So it's the same as the
sun in continuous act of giving light. So my prayers continue, my steps are always in
the act of running after souls and so with all the rest. Otherwise, what great difference
would exist between my operation and that of the great saints? You see, the operation
of the saints was in time and for their time. It doesn't continue forever. All of Jesus's
actions were not only human, they were divine and therefore they are available forever.
Now my daughter, listen to a beautiful, beautiful thing, not yet understood by creatures. All
the things that the soul does together with me and in my will, just as they are my things,
they are hers as well. Both yours is mine. Do you remember? The connection with my will
and her operating together with me participate in the same creative power. So we participate
in God's creative power when we enter into the divine will. That's absolutely fantastic.
So Louisa said she remained ecstatic and with the joy that she couldn't contain and she
said, how is all this possible Lord? And he said, whoever does not understand this can
say they don't understand me. Don't put your two hands up. He says, if you don't understand
this, you don't understand me, it's absolutely amazing. Then he disappeared. But Louisa said,
I can't say it well and I don't know how to explain myself better. Who can tell all that
he made me understand? You see, Louisa gets it all by infused knowledge. So it goes directly
into her spirit and only gradually comes back into her intellect so that she can actually
put words on it. And that's why half the time she understands, but she is not able to articulate
it. Now September the 25th, 1913, the divine will is the center of the soul. Now here we're
coming down to brass tact is excellent. I told the confessor, Louisa said that what Jesus
had said to me that the will of God is the center of the soul and that this center is
in the depth of the soul and that spreading its rays like a sun, it gives light to the
mind, sanctity to the actions, strength to the steps, life to the heart, power to the
word and to everything. What a wonderful definition that is. And not only this, but also that
while this center, the will of God is inside of us so that we may never escape from it.
That is if you're living fully in the divine will and so as to remain at our continuous
disposal, never leaving us alone to separate even for one minute. At the same time, it
is also in front of us to our right to our left behind and everywhere. There's your
breastplate of St. Patrick. Okay. But I want to give you for all of this one Corinthians
316. No, you're not that you are the temple of the living God. So the confessor didn't
agree. And he said that the most holy sacrament is our center. So on coming, Jesus said, my
daughter, I had to make it in such a way that sanctity would be easy and accessible to
all. Now notice he wants everyone to be saints. Unless they didn't want it, the choice is
actually ours. So I had to do this in all conditions, in all circumstances and in every
place. It's true that the most holy sacrament is the center. But who instituted it? Who subdued
my humanity to enclose itself within the small circle of a host? Wasn't it my will? Therefore
my will will always have primacy over everything. Okay. Besides, if everything is in the Eucharist,
the priests who call me down from heaven into their hands and who are in contact with my
sacramental flesh, more than anyone else should be the holiest. That's logic, isn't it? And
they should be the most good. But instead of that, he said some of them are the worst.
That's because they haven't understood or grasped the enormity of the privilege that
they have. Poor me, he said, how they treat me in the most holy sacrament. And the many
devout souls who receive me, perhaps even every day, they should be saints if the center of
the Eucharist were sufficient. But instead, and it's something to be cried over, they
remain always at the same point vain, irritable, punctilious, et cetera. Wow. That means people
are going to communion every day and not growing at all. Isn't that frightening? Okay. That
means that the whole experience is external to you. You've not allowed the Lord to transform
your interior. Now, the opposite of that is a testimony of Saint Therese of Lesus, who
said that she was aware of growing in sanctity every time she received the Eucharist. I've
never come across anybody else who said those words except Therese, that she was aware of
growing in sanctity every time she received the Eucharist. So Jesus is actually answering
the objection of the priest here. And he's saying that if what the priest is saying only,
then the logical thing is that priests and nuns and people going to mass every day, they
should be the holiest people on the earth. We should have no problems in the church,
should we? There's logic. Okay. On the other hand, don't forget that Jesus was a Jew and
they always argue on the one hand and on the other hand. Do you remember the fiddler on
the roof? On the one hand and on the other hand, that's very Jewish. Okay. So on the
other hand, there may be a mother and a watch. This is a very careful example that Jesus
is giving who does my will and who because of her situation, in other words, she's got
tiny infants at home or a sick child or whatever, not because she doesn't want to. She cannot
receive me every day. And one sees that she is patient and she's loving and she carries
the fragrance of the Eucharistic virtues within herself. Ah, is it perhaps the sacrament or
rather my will to which she is submitted that keeps her subdued and makes up for the most
holy sacrament? Isn't that fascinating example? So what what I want to give you there is Luke
10, 29 to 37, the story of the Good Samaritan. The one you think is sort of can't get to
the top and do the writing in the sense of achieving what the others should be achieving
can get there. It's absolutely amazing. So she's doing the will of God at home. She can't
get to mass. It's not her problem. And so the will of God brings her to the holiness.
So even more, I tell you that the sacraments themselves produce fruits according to how
souls are submitted to my will. Please put a VIP, NB or something under. The fruits of
the sacraments depend on how souls are submitted to my will. They produce effects according
to the connection that souls have with the divine will. In other words, a person could
mechanically receive Holy Communion and be in rebellion against God's will in their
souls about something. Therefore they have not got the dispositions to actually let
the fruits of the Holy Eucharist bring them into sanctity because they're in rebellion
against God's will. Does that make sense? And if there's no connection with my will,
they may receive Communion but will remain on an empty stomach. They won't get anything.
They may go to confession. They may still always remain dirty. The priest may say, I forgive
you but the condition for receiving the sacrament of confession and many Catholics don't appear
to me to understand this. The condition is not that the priest will give you absolution.
The condition is the resolution not to sin again. If the resolution not to do that sin
again is not there, then the sacrament isn't even valid. The priest may not know whether
you have that resolution or not or he may not check it out. So they may come before my
sacramental presence that is in the Holy Eucharist in the church. But if our wills do not meet,
I will be as though dead for them because my will alone, now ring the little word alone,
produces all goods and gives life to the very sacraments in the soul who let yourself be
subdued by it. And those who do not understand this, it means that their baby's in religion.
Now that's giving you two, isn't it? So for babies in religion, I want to give you Hebrews
5 verses 11 to 14, Hebrews 5, where the author is saying, you're only on milk and you should
be on solid food at this particular stage, you know. And then for, go back a little bit
and for receiving nothing at Holy Communion, I want to give you one Corinthians 11 verses
17 to 24, sorry 17 to 22 and also verses 27 to 32. That's Paul warning you that you could
receive Communion and actually sin. Is that okay? So let's go on to October the 2nd, 1913,
and I have a VIP on this one as well. When the human will unites to the divine, the life
of Jesus is formed in that soul. Just look what happens to us. So continue in my usual
state. Blessed Jesus made himself seen inside of me, but so identified with me that I could
see his eyes within mine, his mouth within mine. What she's seeing is, she's getting
a vision, a visual picture of what the union is like. Okay. And while I saw this, he said
to me, my daughter, look at how I identify myself with the soul who does my will, who
does my will is lives in my will. Okay. Making myself one with her, I become her very life.
So escalations 220, I no longer live Christ lives in me. And it's also John 14 verses 20
to 21, you and me and I and you. Okay. So I become her very life because my will is inside
and outside of that soul. I was going to tell you four very interesting things. It can be
said number one, that my will is like the air that she breeds, which gives life to everything.
Number two, my will is like light that makes one see and understand everything. Number three,
my will is like heat that warms and fertilizes and makes one grow. And number four, my will
is like heart that palpitates, like hands that work, like feet that walk. And when the
human will unites with the divine will, my life is formed in that soul. Now, he means
his real life. It's not a mystical thing. A mystical thing is not nearly as deep as
his real life living within us. And in all the future volumes, he's going to absolutely
insist that it's his real life. Okay. Then having received communion, Louisa said, I was
saying to Jesus, I love you. Okay. Now you're going to a lovely thing about the rounds here
for the rest of this message. So put a little heading there rounds. My daughter, he said,
do you really want to love me? Say Jesus, I love you with your will. Now he's telling
his straight what to do. Because you see, if we say I love you with your will, then it
means I am loving you with a divine love. If I simply say I love you, I'm only loving
him with the human love. Okay. So I love you with your will. And since my will fills heaven
and earth, your love will surround me everywhere. And your I love you will resound up there
in the heavens and down into the deepest abysses. Isn't that absolutely amazing? Now, I wonder
what he means by abysses. I wouldn't imagine hell is listening with you. No. So all the
poor souls in purgatory are hearing this wonderful love coming off from the earth. Okay. In the
same way, if you want to say I adore you, I bless you, I praise you. You will say it,
unite it with my will. So I adore you with your will, I bless you with your will and
so on. And you will feel heaven and earth with adoration, blessings, praises and with
thanksgiving. And we do it in the name of all. And so we're saying to the Lord, I want
you to take it with the whole human race is saying this, that is past, present and future.
In my will, things are simple, easy and immense. My will is everything so much so that my very
attributes, what are they? A simple act of my will. So if justice, goodness, wisdom,
fortitude, for example, follow their course, my will precedes them, accompanies them and
places them in the attitude of working. In some, they do not move from one point of my
volition. Therefore, whoever takes my will takes everything. Now, will you please color
that with some color that's going to make you really look at it? That if you take the
divine will, you take everything. Even more, she can say that her own life is ended. And
so you, what is ended? It means the weaknesses have ended, the temptations, the passions,
the miseries have ended, because all things lose their rights in one who does my will.
Her my will has primacy over everything and the right to everything. That's a wonderful
statement, isn't it? Okay. And so one of the ways in which throughout these writings,
the Lord gives you hints of how to discern, you know, if you ask the question, where am
I at? What you've just read will help you to discern. We don't know absolutely where
we're at. But it helps you to discern whether you're in a healthy place or a place you need
to shift from. Okay, because he says that if we're genuinely living in the divine will,
we will notice that the weaknesses and the temptations and the passions go down, down,
they're not the upper. They're not the things that are taking over. They're not the things
that are occupying your mind. They're actually going lesser and lesser and lesser until you
reach the point that Louisa reached where she didn't remember them. There's one wonderful
moment where Louisa's going through agony. Now, it must be a higher volume than this.
I don't know. I can't quote the volumes at this stage. I'm teaching to many of the volumes
at the same time. But she said to Jesus, she was in such agony, she said, I can actually
feel myself. You know, I would consider that perfectly normal. But for her, she was so
taken up in the divine will that to get back up to actually feeling her body, she thought
she had done something drastic. Now, that's miles ahead of what's being said here. Okay,
but that's the discernment. The passions die down. All of this stuff dies down. The weaknesses,
the miseries, and you're not in the struggles you were in before. It's one of the bits
of discernment. Isn't it a good bit of discernment? So November the 18th, 1913, when the human
will and the divine are opposed, one forms the cross of the other. And he gives a very
interesting description of this. And Louisa said she was thinking about her poor state
and how even the cross has banished from her. Okay. Now, for Louisa Galatians 614 fits perfectly.
As for me, the one thing I can boast about is the cross of our Lord Jesus Christ through
whom the world is crucified to me and I to the world. And that's that's Louisa. Okay,
that's Galatians 614. So Jesus is going to give her an example, which is the exact opposite
of that. And the example is for us who are at a much lesser place than Louisa. My daughter,
he said, when two wills are opposed to each other, one forms the cross of the other. The
way we would say that in Ireland is you have trouble if two wills cross each other. You
have heavy weather. Okay. But Jesus is using this language because of what he wants to
say. So it is between as that's the way it is between me and souls. When their wills
are opposed to mine, I form their cross and they form mine. In other words, if we are
opposing the Lord, he has to try and bring you back towards his will. So you're going
to meet opposition from him. So he forms your cross. And because we're opposing him, we
create suffering for him. So we become his cross and he becomes ours. And there's another
bit of discernment for you. And that is that the more we live surrendered to the divine
will, the less this crossing happens. Less and less and less and less. Jesus said, I am
the long beam of the cross and they're the short one. And crossing each other, they form
the cross. Now, when the will of the soul unites with mine, the beams are no longer crossed
but united and therefore the cross is no longer a cross. That's the language he's using here.
There's a wonderful statement from a saint, you may not know, St. Madeline Duclerc. Do
you ever heard of her? She's the founder of the community of Sacred Heart Sisters. I think
that's what they're called. And her statement is that the surrendered soul has found paradise
on earth. You see the surrendered soul is the one who has surrendered to the divine will.
So then you've got the paradise of the divine will taking over. Okay. So the cross is no
longer a cross. Have you understood? And he said, besides that, I sanctified the cross.
It was not the cross that sanctified me. The cross was an instrument of shame, but Jesus
sanctified it. It's not the cross that sanctifies. It's the resignation to my will that sanctifies
the cross. That's terribly, terribly important. The church has taught that all down the centuries.
It's not the fact that you're sick that makes makes you wonderful in the eyes of God. It's
the fact that you have surrendered to the divine will, whether he wants to heal you
or take your home. That is the important thing. The surrender to the divine will is the resignation
to my will that sanctifies the cross. Therefore, even the cross can do as much good in so far
as it's connected to my will. But if you've got somebody going in rebellion against God
for something that happens, how can God be a good God and do it to me? That's rebellion
against God's will. So if they're like that, then they're going to have lots of opposition
coming against them. So the cross can only do good in so far as it's connected with the
divine will. Not only this, the cross sanctifies and crucifies part of the person, but my will
doesn't spare anything. It sanctifies everything. Now you have to watch this one. It crucifies
the thoughts, the desires, the will, the affection, the heart, everything. Now, if you studied
the works of Saint John of the Cross as I did, he says, he's 16th century, he said that
God gives us two great purifications in life. Among purification is the ordinary stuff that
hits us in everyday life, you know, doing the stuff that goes against you and things
that happen in you and in your family and among people and all the rest. He said, that's
the first purification. And the people who are generous with God, most of them will take
that and they'll go on. But he said, the second purification is completely interior and most
people won't take it. That's the purification of the thoughts, the desires, the will, the
affections, the heart. Now, for someone going into divine will, you have to allow this interior
purification because the divine will's spirituality is in completely interior, completely. And
if the divine will is to operate in me, he can't be meeting dirty rooms in my thought
life and he can't be meeting shabby things in my desires. And he can't be meeting on
healthy things in my will and my affections and so on. Everything has to be purified
so that the divine will can actually reign on the earth. Am I making sense? Therefore,
we have to say yes to the interior purification and he will do it to the extent that you allow
it. And so it's entirely up to yourself, if you say to the Lord, look, I want the divine
will, 100% do what you like. If we say that to him and actually mean it, he will take
it on from there. That's like me entering a school for training pilots. I say, I want
to be a pilot. I'm not just coming here to look at the rest of you. You know what I
mean? And not only that, but I want to be a bomber pilot or I want to be a disc pilot
or that pilot or the other pilot, depending on what I want to be, will depend on how they
will train me. Does that make sense? Yeah. It's exactly the same with the Lord. So there's
a decision here that goes on between myself and the Lord and nobody else. It's like that
wonderful moment when Mactimilian Colby was six years old and he had a vision of our
lady and she offered him the white crown of purity in the priesthood and the red crown
of martyrdom. And this kid, whose mother had told him he was incorrigible only an hour earlier,
said I'll have the two when he got the two. He asked for the whole package deal. Now a
number of the saints actually asked the Lord for the whole package deal. St. Therese was
one of them as well. Okay. So it's it's like I want to get there. I don't care about the
price. Oh, that's actually terribly important. Now Jesus says, my will is light. Now I want
to give you one Timothy 616, one Timothy 616, God dwells in unapproachable light. Okay.
I also give you one John 1 5 that God is light. But you see, as you as we go on in these volumes,
you will see that God dwells in unapproachable light. It's only in the divine will that he
brings us into this light and he'll bring you deeper and deeper and deeper as you surrender
to the divine will. Okay. It shows to the soul the necessity of this sanctification and complete
crucifixion. Matthew 5 17. So this this divine light of the divine will shows us the necessity
of this purification that we need. In such a way that she herself incites me, we would
say encourages me to accomplish the crafting of my will upon her. In other words, we actually
give him permission to go ahead, even though we won't like the process. Therefore the cross
and the other virtues are content as long as they get something. But if they can pierce
the soul with three nails, they boast of their triumph. On the other hand, my will, which
does not know how to do incomplete works, is not content with just three nails, but with
as many nails for as many acts of my will, which I dispose for that soul. Now I said
a lot in that last breath. Okay. Watch this again. He says, if you're living just the
ordinary spirituality before divine will, the virtues, in other words, the level of sanctity
that a soul can reach, if it reaches what he calls the three nails, in other words, that
you've allowed suffering, then most people are satisfied. Okay. But he says the divine
will might start there, but it certainly doesn't finish there. The divine will once, as many
nails for as many acts, in other words, every act in the divine will has to be complete
and perfect. There can be nothing of me in it. Yet there's something of me in it, meaning
the negative side of me, then it's not an act of the divine will. And he said, look at
this, for as many acts of my will, which I dispose for that soul, in other words, he
has disposed for each one of us to give a certain number of acts to him. And each one
of us has to do our, well, as the children would say, we have to do our acres. You have
to do it. The divine will is expecting a certain amount. Okay. Now for that, I want to give
you Galatians 524. Galatians 524. You cannot belong to Christ Jesus unless you crucify
all self-indulgent passions and desires. Paul seemed to understand. And he backed their
2000 years. You cannot belong to Christ Jesus unless you crucify all self-indulgent. Now Paul
has already described that the way of self-indulgence is that way and the way of the Holy Spirit
is that way. They're two entirely different ways. Okay. And what Paul was asking for there
is the 100% giving. So November the 27th, 1913. And I have a VIP on this one as well.
The divine will is the highest point that can exist, both in heaven and in earth. It's
the highest point. So we're being called to the highest point. So Jesus said to Louisa,
my daughter, "As many complete acts of my will as the soul performs, so many parts of
me does she take into herself." And the more she takes of my will, the more light she acquires
forming the sun within herself. Now the sun is a source of light. Okay. Now notice for
each complete act, a complete act is that you have done an act in the divine will and the
divine will is fully involved and your will has surrendered fully to the divine will.
Okay. It's a complete act. It's not just me wishing I was doing something in the divine
will. Now for each complete act in the divine will, we take a part of Jesus into us. So
if we do many divine acts, we're taking many parts of him into us. And the more we do than
the more we are incorporating Jesus into us. That's what he's saying. That's why I have
a VIP on it. And you create Jesus as you create a sun within yourself. And this sun is formed
by the light that she takes from my will. Now the light is the divine will. So that means
we're taking part of this light into ourselves. And the rays of this sun are linked to the
rays of my divine sun. So each one is reflected in the other, each one flashes through the
other and they dart through each other. And as they do this, the sun that my will has formed
in the soul becomes larger and larger. Now he will tell you in the higher volumes that
your capacity when we start is very, very small. And the more we respond to the divine
will and the more acts we do, that he enlarges our soul so that we can take more. And then
he enlarges it and he keeps on enlarging it as long as you will do acts in the divine
will. So your capacity for God at the end of your living in the divine will on earth
will be incredibly greater than when you started. And the thing is that if you're doing, if
you're filling your life with these acts, when you go to heaven, you're starting at
a point that many of the saints in heaven have not arrived at yet. Why? Because you've
done all of this on earth. So you know a relay race, they start at different points. You'll
be starting way ahead of many saints. That's amazing, isn't it? And you will know God more
than them because you have operated in the divine will all the time. Many, many souls
wait until death to surrender to the divine will. So and then the purification that they
didn't accept on earth has to be done in purgatory. And Jesus keeps telling us, and we're going
to see this in the next message that for a person actually genuinely living in the divine
will there cannot be purgatory because it's been done in all the purification of the thoughts
and the words and the actions and the this and that and the other. The purification is
done. And so the soul goes directly to heaven. Is that the most incredible God news? Yeah.
So let's read it slowly. This and the next message go together and they're absolutely
brilliant. So that sun will be formed in the soul, become larger and larger. So Louisa
said, here he is again. He's talking about his will. Jesus said, because obviously Louisa
didn't grasp. We find it difficult to take on board with the greatness of this. He said,
my will is the highest point which can exist both in heaven and on earth. So you enter heaven
at a very high point. And when the soul has reached it, she has subdued everything and
has done everything. I put VIP in the margin for myself. In other words, when we have given
our will, 100% to him, he asks for nothing else. Now, if you want a summary of the Old
Testament, it's this, I own the ever asked you to do my will and you have rebelled completely
against it. That's a summary of the entire Old Testament. I only ever asked you to do
my will. So Jesus said that when we have reached this point, there's nothing left for her to
do but to dwell over these heights, enjoy them. This is why the eagle is the symbol of the
soul and the divine will. So you're living up at the great heights. Enjoy them and understand
this will of mine more and more, which is not yet understood well, either in heaven or on
earth. Now, why would you say it's not understood well in heaven? Well, only the saints had surrendered
to the divine will on earth, but they hadn't lived in the divine will. And all the others
only surrendered in debt. So they started back much further. It's an incredible thing.
But all our acts in the divine will enhance all the saints. They can participate in them,
which is really amazing. And the souls in poetry can participate as well. He gave it
that last week, didn't he? So Jesus said, there is much time for you to be spent in the
divine will because you've understood very little. Now, this is 1914 and Louisa won't
die until 1947. So she's got time yet to grasp it. And like Louisa, we cannot understand
these writings to a certain extent, but actually taking it in and registering the fullness
is another matter altogether. And I find that when I go back to an earlier volume that I've
talked before, and I read it, I say, you sure you read that before? It comes across completely
new, completely new. We're not able to actually absorb everything we read intellectually. You
may understand it at the moment. So that's why a lot of medicine of reading has got to
be done. Yeah. And we've got to say to the Lord, look, will you put that into my spirit?
The head won't take it. Sometimes our intellect can't take it. So we just say to him, just
put it in. It's like a child not understanding nutrition, but it opens the mouth and the
mother puts the food in anyway, and the child gets the benefit, you know? So we don't always
have to understand to benefit from this. So my will, Jesus said, is so great that whoever
does it, that lives in it, can call himself a God on the earth. Notice a small J. Now for
that, I want to give you Sam 82, verse six, Sam 82, verse six. I said you are God's, all
of you sons of the most high. Okay. I also want to give you Sam eight. Lord, what is man
that you would even think about him or mortal man that you'd give him a second thought,
and yet you've made him little less than a God with glory and honor, you've crowned
him, giving him power over the works of your hands. Now, so my will is so great that whoever
does it can call himself a God on the earth. And just as my will forms the beatitude of
heaven, these gods who do my will form the beatitude of the earth and of those who are
near them, because the more peace and serenity and unity and grace and everything that goes
into you, everybody around you benefits, even on a completely nonverbal level, even if they
don't ever acknowledge it. It's actually happening. That's like saying, if I lift up the blinds
in the morning, the sun will come in or the light will come in and everything in the room
will benefit. The light doesn't say, well, I'll only go to this place or that place and
they don't deserve it and this one does. The light doesn't do that. And it's the same,
not only in the house you live in, but in the area you live in, the country you live
in, everybody benefits. That's the incredible thing about the divine will. So they formed
the beatitude of the earth and of those who are near them. There's no good that exists
on the earth, which is not to be attributed to these gods of my will. Isn't that absolutely
incredible? He says many times in Louisa's writings that he only looks after the earth
because of the people living at this level. So whether as direct or indirect cause, everything
is due to them. Just as there is no happiness in heaven which doesn't come from me, so there's
no good on the earth which doesn't come from them. So beside that, I wanted to put Romans
8 verses 19 to 23 because in that text Paul says that the whole of creation is waiting
for the sons of God to stand up and to bring everything back into God's order. And we know
now that these sons of God are the people living in the divine will.
So March the 8th, 1914, as the soul lives and dies in the divine will. That's the incredible
privilege to die in the divine will. There's no good which she doesn't carry with herself.
The value of one single instant in the divine will. Isn't that amazing? So this is an extremely
important message. So we'll skip the introductory bit and Jesus said to Louisa, "My daughter,
the soul who lives in my will." This is a wonderful thing. I want you to list it. One,
two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten. Now the soul who lives in my will can
say of everything I do, it's mine. This because the will of the soul is so identified with
mine that whatever my will does, she does as well. So as she lives and dies in my volition,
that's number one. Everything is yours is mine. So this is a number two. As she lives
and dies in my volition, there's no good which she does not carry with herself because there
is no good which my will does not contain. So you go to heaven very, very enriched.
Okay. Number three, my will is the life of all the good that creatures do. We would say
the source of everything. The next number, therefore, as the soul dies in my will, she
carries with her, watch this, the masses that are celebrated, the prayers and the good works
that are done because they are all the fruits of my will. That's a good deal of baggage,
isn't it? Now the next number, that's one, two, three, four, number five, isn't it? And
this is still very little, he said, compared to the working of my will itself, which the
soul carries with her as her own. Number six, one instant of the working in my will is enough
to surpass all the works of all creatures past, present and future. That the only thing you
do with this stuff is read it very slowly and try and take it in. So the next number,
so as the soul dies in my will, there is no beauty that matches her nor heights, riches,
sanctity, wisdom or love, nothing, nothing can equal her because she's carrying God back
to God. Isn't that incredible? Now the next number, as the soul who dies in my will enters
the heavenly fatherland, not only will the heavens gates open, but the entire heaven
will bow to welcome her into the celestial dwelling. That means all the saints and all
the angels because this soul goes back to God with more privilege and more riches than
all the saints put together because they didn't live in the divine will on earth. So the entire
heaven will bow to welcome her into the celestial dwelling, to honor the working of my will.
What should I tell you then of the feast and the surprise of all the blessed in seeing
this soul completely marked, no to the completely, that's a hundred percent because we're dealing
with someone, a hundred percent given to the Lord, completely marked by the working of
my divine will. In seeing in this soul, one who has done everything in my will, this is
the next number, that everything she has done during her life, each saying, each thought,
each word, each work, each action of hers are many suns that adorn her. Now you can
see why he told us a couple of messages back that we needed the thoughts and the words
and everything else purified so that they could become these great suns so they could
become something completely divine. Each one will be different from the other in light
and in beauty and in seeing this soul, many divine rivelets that will inundate all the
blessed is the next number. In other words, everybody in heaven will benefit from the
riches that this soul brings back. They will inundate all the blessed and flow also upon
earth for the good of pilgrim souls since heaven cannot contain them. I find that absolutely
fascinating. And I want you to put John 7 37 to 39 and you'll get a new understanding
of it because Jesus said, if you come and drink out of your own heart will flow fountains
of living water. Now we understood that this means that you have plenty to help other
people on earth. But Jesus is saying that the soul who goes back to heaven with the fullness
of the divine will has so much that heaven can't hold it and it has to flow out onto
the earth like that. Unbelievable, isn't it? I find that very hard to take in. Can you
take that in? I mean, I can read it in my intellect, sort of understands the English,
but the concept. Wow, it's incredible. Yeah. And my daughter, Jesus said, and this is the
next number. My will is the portant of portants. It is the secret to finding light, sanctity
and riches. It is the secret to all goods. But it is not known and therefore not appreciated
nor loved. You at least, he said, appreciate and love it and make it known to those whom
you see disposed. Now will you underline that last bit? You must only introduce to the divine
will to people who are ready. Don't introduce to the people who are not ready. You'll only
get a very negative kickback. They just won't understand. But to those who are disposed,
another day, Louisa said, as I was suffering, I felt that I was unable to do anything I
felt oppressed. But Jesus said, my daughter, do not worry yourself. Try only to be abandoned
in my will. That's terribly important. The surrendered soul has found paradise on earth.
Try only to be abandoned to my will. And I will do everything for you. He said, because
one single instant in my will is worth more than all the good you could possibly do in
your entire life. Now I think you need to put some kind of a big ring around that to make
sure you actually will come back to this and really look at it. One single instant in my
will is worth more than all the good you could possibly do in your entire life. Now you know
the value of a divine will act. And nobody has to encourage you to do them after that.
Because when we know that something is really, really worth it, it makes all the difference,
doesn't it? Okay. And then Louisa said that on another day, Jesus said, my daughter, one
who truly does my will, that is lives in my will, in everything that occurs within her,
both in the soul and in the body, in whatever she feels or suffers, she can say, Jesus is
suffering, Jesus is oppressed, Jesus is walking, Jesus is whatever. In fact, everything that
souls do to me reaches me, even in the soul in whom I dwell. Oh, sorry. In fact, everything
that souls do to me reaches me, even in the soul in whom I dwell, who does my will. That
means if the divine will is in us, Jesus is in us. And so everything that souls do reaches
him and it will reach him in us as well. So as we develop, we will feel the pain or the
distress or whatever, and we make reparation for it. So if the coldness of souls reaches
me, my will feels it. And since my will is the life of the soul, that's the one living
in the divine will, it happens as a consequence that the soul feels it too. So the next time
you feel kind of coldness in prayer and that don't just presume it's yours, that it's somebody
else that the Lord wants you to make reparation or substitution for them. It changes everything
when you just think of it that way. You say, Lord, you know, this thing that I'm feeling,
if that's coming from somebody who's in desperate need, then I want to join you in making reparation
for that person. So instead of troubling yourself over this coldness, see what he's saying.
As if it was her own, she must remain around me to console me and repair for the coldness
that souls send me. So there you have it. In the same way, if she feels distractions,
oppressions and other things, she must remain around me to relieve me and repair because
those are not hard things. They're the ones coming at me from other souls. That's a nice
little bit of discernment for you, isn't it? That whatever you're feeling inside that you
say to the Lord, this is somebody in need. And sometimes, as happens to me last night,
a name will come into your head for no reason that you can think of. And I realize that
soul needs to be prayed for. Why should I think of that person now? Like the name that came
into my head last night hadn't been in my head for over 20 years. And because of the
age of the person who was named as was, I realized he was probably dying. But it didn't
come to be under about three in the morning, the hour of mercy. So I'm just alerting you
to the fact that all of us will get things like this. It's to be alert to the message.
I said that the hour of mercy, that person is probably dying, immediately bathed them
in the precious blood of the lamb. And this is our privilege that we can help people so
incredibly. So they're not necessarily your things, but mine, Jesus said. Therefore, the
soul who lives of my will that lives out of the divine will feel many different pains
according to the offenses that souls give to me. But in a sudden way, and almost in
one's start, because I noticed that when I prayed for that name that came to me during
the night, once I had bathed that person at the precious blood of the lamb, instant sleep
came. So you just need to be alert to the fact that you're being asked to do this for
somebody at a very important moment. So on the other hand, she will also feel indescribable
joys and contentment. And if in the first, she must occupy herself with consoling and
repairing me in the joys and contentment, she also must delight. Only then does my will
find my own interest. In other words, his interest is in the salvation of soul. Otherwise
it would remain saddened and unable to carry out who have my volition contains. Now, another
day he said, and this is a VIP one. And if you tell people this who don't understand
all the other things in the divine will, they're going to tell you you're crazy. My daughter,
who does my will that lives in my will, can by no means go to purgatory. Now, look who's
speaking. It's the Lord himself. Because my will purges the soul of everything. We've
had that in the previous messages. After keeping her so jealousy during her life in the custody
of my volition, how could I allow the fire of purgatory to touch her? At the most, she
may lack some clothing. I absolutely love that. You may need a dip. Do you know what
I mean? But my will before revealing the divinity to her will clothe her with all that she
may lack. Isn't that something else? And then he said, I reveal myself. So about that clothing
I want to give you some references in the scriptures. That clothing is the garment of
grace and the garment of salvation. So I want to give it to you in Genesis 3, 7, first.
That before Adam and Eve sinned, you're told specifically they were now wearing clothes.
But after they sinned, you were told they were naked, which has nothing to do with clothes.
Because they didn't have clothes before or after. And they were told that God made clothes
for them later. And that means that God has to re-clot them in grace. So Mark 5, 15 is
a demoniac that Jesus clothehed after he delivered him. Luke 15, 22 is the prodigal son, gets
the garment of grace when he goes back to the Father. And there's a wonderful one in
Revelation 16, 15. And if you just read it out of context, you'd say it's very strange.
Revelation 16, 15, 16, 15. Now Revelation 16, 15 says, John says that when the Lord returns,
make sure you're not found without your clothes. And somebody not understanding Scripture and
reading that would think that he's talking about streaking. And John is saying that when
the Lord returns, make sure you have your garment of salvation because he will be returning
in judgment. You see, so it's the garment of salvation. And it's represented by that
white garment we put on a child in baptism. So we'll do another one. Mark 14, 1914. How
hard it is for Jesus not to content the one who does his will and takes the whole of him.
Now notice the whole of him. So here's your Jewish or anime 6, 4 to 10. Love the Lord
your God with all your hearts, soul, mind and being. Okay. So Louisa said, today I was
fusing all of myself in Jesus, but so much so as to feel the whole of Jesus alive. Look
at this and real within me. This is not some kind of just sort of mystical grace. This
is a genuine by location of the Lord. Is that okay? While I was feeling him, he said
to me in such a tender and touching ways to make my heart crack, she said, my daughter,
it is too hard for me not to content one who lives in my will. Do you see, I've no more
hands nor feet nor heart nor eyes nor mouth. I have nothing left. It's my will, which you
have taken you in my will, you took possession of everything. So I've nothing left. This
is why in spite of the many grave evils that inundate the earth, the deserved chastisements
are not pouring upon it because it's hard for me not to content you. Isn't that amazing?
Because of one person, he'd hold back all the chastisements. Besides, how can I do that
if I have no hands and you do not give them to me? If they become absolutely necessary
to me, I will be forced to steal them from you or to convince you that you yourself would
give them to me how hard it is for me, how hard it is for me to displease one who does
my will. Isn't that absolutely amazing? The church has always taught us that we are his
hands and feet, haven't we? We are his tongue, we are his eyes and ears because we're the
body of Christ. Jesus says that if you take that up to the level of the divine mode and
the divine will, that he finds it extremely difficult not to content you. I think you should
remember that, shouldn't you? So Larisa said, I remain surprised at this teaching. My book
says, speaking. It's a teaching. Not only this, but I could really see that I had the
hands, feet and the eyes of Jesus and so on. And I said to him, Jesus, let me come. Let
me come. Of course, let me die. He said, give me a little more life in you and then you
will come. This is only 1914 and she has until 14. Well, not really. It depends on whether
it's his eternal clock or your time clock. Yes, of course. Yeah, with the Lord a thousand
years is like a single day. So this is 1914 and she will live until 47. So what he's saying
is, will you give me a little bit of your time on the earth? This is extremely important
and I'm going to stop there. It's so important to want to stop there because he's saying
the only time that you can do anything for God is on the earth. Once your job is over,
you can't do anything more from it's on the earth that we have the privilege of serving
God and we have the privilege of doing things for the Kingdom of God and lending Jesus our
eyes and our ears and our mouth and our hands and our feet and everything. It's fantastic,
isn't it? Yeah. So I want to leave it there because it's very rich food tonight.